so for a long time every time we hear a
negative comment from Donald Trump about
Hispanics for example it's always
defended as he's not against Hispanics
it's just that you know some of them are
rapists and we're not getting the best
people from Mexico but some of them are
good people and every time we start to
think maybe Trump is a little bit
Islamophobic we are meant to believe we
are told to believe no no it's not that
he's against Muslims they are his
friends it's that he's just against
terrorists and if that's all true then
Trump is doing some really odd things
with his Twitter account because he has
retweeted three absolutely insane videos
about Muslims from an extreme right-wing
group in the United Kingdom the three
tweets are from Jada Frandsen now you
might be saying well hold our Jada
France and who is Jada Francine Branson
is the second-in-command of a British
right-wing party called Britain first
Britain first is anti-immigration anti
Islam it's one of these right-wing
nationalist parties that have sort of
seen a bit of a rise actually over the
last year or two she was recently
convicted last year I think it was for
religiously aggravated harassment
against a woman who was wearing Muslim
attire and three tweets of hers that
Donald Trump decided to retweet number
one the first tweet purports to show a
Muslim immigrant attacking a handicapped
man the second video purports to show a
Muslim individual destroying a statue of
the Virgin Mary and then the third video
claims to be of a Muslim immigrant
beating up a handicapped Dutch kid so
they're sort of three different issues
here that we need to discuss number one
is are the videos linked to even real in
the sense that they even are what they
claim to be second even if the videos
are what they claim to be do three
videos about individual anecdotal
interpersonal conflict really tell us
anything about Muslims as a group of
people that would be useful to us that's
question number two and then question
number three is either way no matter
what we learn or don't learn from these
videos should the President of the
United States
be retweeting material like this now
let's start with the veracity of the
videos the last one is about a boy on
crutches who is attacked or knocked down
by a supposedly Muslim individual it's a
fake video okay the source of that video
has gone public and said it's an old
video of a Dutch man hitting a kid the
Dutch man is neither an immigrant nor a
Muslim so at least one of these three
videos is totally faked the others I
don't know whether they're true or not
but it doesn't really matter okay
because we get to question two and
question two is even if these videos are
accurate even if these videos depict
honestly what they are what they are
sensibly depict does it tell us anything
about what policy should be towards
Muslims as a group of people or to
immigrants from majority Muslim nations
or whatever and the answer is no three
videos tell us nothing even if they are
accurate and true videos but the real
issue here is that the President of the
United States is tweeting retweeting the
messages of a convicted harasser of
Muslims who's associated with an
extremist national party in another
country why would the president do that
retweeting these videos is not going to
catalyze some kind of nuanced and
productive discussion about dealing with
actual Islamic extremism retweeting this
stuff is not going to further our
understanding of the problems of the
world in some way
the only possible effect of Donald Trump
retweeting these videos is to foment
hatred and possibly violence against
Muslim individuals merely because they
are Muslim there is actually a case to
be made for Donald Trump to have his
Twitter account suspended for retweeting
these videos because he's retweeting
hateful content that you could very
realistically argue violates the Terms
of Service of Twitter now I would be
shocked if Trump gets blocked from
Twitter I don't think it's going to
happen but the only point here and I
wonder Pat if someone would disagree
with me what is there to gain from
retweeting these videos other than maybe
fomenting violence against Muslims I
can't think of anything what do you
think Trump thinks he's do
I mean it's just kind of like dog
whistling in a way right I mean the idea
even when you retweet something you can
put in your own commentary yes notice
how he didn't do that if the cowardly
move I would actually have preferred
that instead of just hitting the retweet
button Donald Trump used the quote
retweet which is where you're retweeting
something but you can add a line or two
or 200 and whatever 280 characters I
guess now it is and explain to us what's
the message we should be getting from
this content that you're retweeting is
it that you really like the Britain
first party is it that you really like
the person who's doing the retweets is
it that because of these three incidents
in the UK we should ban people from Iraq
from coming to the United States like
make the connection connect the dots for
me yeah I mean tell us how you feel
otherwise it comes across as super
cowardly I I completely agree I would
love an explanation and there has been
no explanation issued so far the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad